hello I'm Greg Sadler and I would like
to tell you all about an online course
that I have available called
philosophical World Views and values
nine philosophical perspectives and it
is a completely asynchronous course
which means that you can take it
whenever you want to you just register
for it and you can take as long as you
want you can work through the course
multiple times once you actually are
enrolled you have lifetime access to the
course it's based on an academic class
that I was brought in to teach at Marist
College as one of their online offerings
for their school of professional study
so this is for you know Learners who
weren't you know regular traditional age
college students people who had
professional lives and the goal was to
introduce them to a number of different
interesting valuable perspectives lots
of different ways to do that and the way
that I chose to do it was by working
through some key philosophical texts
that are incredibly rich in ideas and
have been massively influential on the
world that we live in so I oriented it
towards the history of ideas and
philosophy there's a lot of stuff in
there with ethics social theory
philosophy of human nature metaphysics
the theory of knowledge and I try to
provide some historical context and
continuity between the various thinkers
as we work through these themes so I'll
tell you who we actually study in the
course we begin with Plato we have some
selections from one of his most
important works the Republic and there
we look at the nature of the human soul
what you know knowledge really is the
theory of the forms and the ways in
which we as human beings reflect our
society and vice versa and how we become
good or bad people then in continuing on
in the ancient period we go to the great
sto thinker epicus his enidan or
handbook and portions of his discourses
it's a great introduction to stoic
thought as a contrast to Plato but a lot
of the same key themes are coming up
what is the nature of the human being
what's our connection with the universe
how do we become better people or risk
becoming worse people and then we have a
thinker who brings these together and
places them in a different different
context and that is boethus we read the
entirety of his
consolation of philosophy which he
writes while under house arrest awaiting
execution and there are platonic and a
stoic and other ideas woven into it but
he goes further in thinking about some
of these key ideas then we move on into
the modern period we look at two key
early thinkers uh Renee de cart's
discourse on method where he's laying
out a radical new approach in philosophy
and not just philosophy but life in
general and delves into all sorts of
interesting questions like the nature of
the body and mind connection all the way
to whether human beings animals and
machines are radically different from
each other or whether there might be
some connection between those then we
look at his contemporary Thomas Hobs and
we read through study and uh explore
parts of his Masterwork the leviathon
books one and two just selections from
them looking at how he understands the
human mind and his his view on the state
of nature as a pretty uh dangerous one
how we get out of that through the
social contract and then what Society
ought to look like we have a kind of
counterposition to Hobs with somebody
who's a great critic of him Jean jaac
rouso and we work through the discourse
on the origins of inquality among human
beings another really important work and
then we look at a Critic of rouso from a
equality feminist perspective Mary wool
stonecraft her massive ly important
Vindication of the rights of women we
look through portions of that work and a
number of the different social dynamics
that she's interested in she is also a
virtue ethicist so we see ideas from
Plato and epicus and buus being carried
forward in the Modern Age and then we
move on to two thinkers of the 19th and
20th Century who have been incredibly
influential in Social Theory one of them
is Carl Marx we look at his short piece
alienated or estranged labor and then we
look at the Communist Manifesto what is
it actually saying this is a a a very
important work for understanding uh what
has motivated millions of human beings
in the 20th century and still has
influence today and then we look at
Martin Luther King two selections from
him probably the most famous pieces that
that he has the I Have a Dream speech
that everybody knows one line from but
we we explore the entire speech and then
we look at his letter from a Birmingham
Jail so you notice that there's a lot of
key themes how Society should be
structured how human beings can improve
themselves or morally decline inequality
what is its basis does it have any
legitimacy what is should our our
metaphysics be there's all sorts of
really
interesting
intersecting issues that we're going to
explore now let's talk about the
nitty-gritty what do you actually get if
you enroll in this class well the way I
have it structured is with the same
resources that I developed for my own
online students back when I was teaching
this as an academic class at Marist
College in the uh
201s so there's over 50 lecture video
videos uh all of them begin with a
lecture video about The Thinker their
historical context the text itself and
then we get into the key ideas that are
being worked out um there's over 35
lesson pages that I produced almost like
a mini textbook within the course
there's over 25 printable downloadable
handouts that you can use to help wrap
your head around the idea is we have
have uh study questions there's quizzes
that you can use to test your knowledge
and other resources as well that you
might find quite useful for developing
your own understanding of these
influential texts and thinkers that I
selected for this class so this is a
course that is available in the study
with Sadler teachable Academy it's one
that uh is the earliest one that I
created it's a class that was also the
first online class that I ever taught so
I'm kind of proud of it it's like my
little you know baby in a way and I
invite you to take a look at what's
available you'll see a link below to the
class if you want to enroll in it glad
to see you there you'll be seeing a lot
more of me in the the class videos uh if
you're just curious about it you know
you can check it out you can always ask
me further questions
about the course and uh you can always
read the thinkers on your own as well
but I've created a course that will help
you much better develop a a solid
understanding of who these people are
what their texts are saying and why
they're important to us in the 21st
century